hey what's up guys Samuel Leeds here and
I've had a lot of people on my Facebook
group saying that they want to see an
interview on my youtube channel with
myself and Robert Kiyosaki but I've gone
one step further than that rather than
doing an interview on YouTube
I have put on a dinner where I'm gonna
be interviewing him live and I'm gonna
let some of my youtube fans come for
dinner with me and Robert Kiyosaki I
mean this is just crazy mind-boggling
stuff so the day is gonna be Friday the
3rd of May and it's going to be very
very intimate we've got very very
limited spaces available because it will
be an intimate dinner where you'll love
the chance to come down meet Robert
Kiyosaki
get a photo with him asking questions
see me what an opportunity in a lifetime
so I've put a little link below with the
disc with the with a link booking do
book quickly to avoid disappointment
I think the tickets are like sixteen
hundred pound plus v80 which personally
I think just for a picture with Robert
Kiyosaki alone is worth it and we'll
have a great night too so get yourself
booked on come and meet me come and meet
Robert Kiyosaki change your life forever
what a life-changing opportunity so see
you soon peace out